bonsoir la colère d'une femme pour
débuter ce jour mal à placer sa mère
âgée de 87 ans dans un ehpad haut de
gamme situé dans le centre de nantes
mais vous allez le voir les services
selon elles sont très loin d'être haut
de gamme elle parle même de
dysfonctionnements dans cette maison de
retraite à la même porté plainte
explications boris diop dominique launay
daniel est en colère sa maman à 87 ans
il souffrait de la maladie d'alzheimer
ne se lève plus de son lit et ne prend
même plus ses médicaments elle a été
accueillie dans cet ehpad haut de gamme
en 2013 à l'occasion de son ouverture un
établissement du groupe orpea flambant
neuf sur l'île de nantes je suis en
colère parce que les soins ne sont pas
respectées vendredi ma fille s'est
rendue vers word sa grand mère elle
n'avait pas eu de toilette
samedi je me suis rendu avec mon mari il
n'y avait pas toilettes de fait dans la
chambre c'était une puanteur
maman tu veux j'ai trouvé que maman
coucher parce que malgré les publicités
faites par cette maison de stimulation
des pathologies d'alzheimer aucune
simulation de maman est toujours couché
un mécontentement qui en appelle un
autre cette fois ci à l'intérieur de
l'ehpad de la part d'une salariée de la
résidence pour personnes âgées qui
témoigne de façon anonyme et qui se
plaint de démissions à répétition côté
personnel et d'un manque d'effectif pour
s'occuper des 75 résidents
à
l'arrivée pour faire visiter les jambes
tousse n'y a pas de souci après pouvoir
faut voir comment les personnages y sont
ici et ça je pense jeu porté vers et se
sont laissés comment dans leurs choix
entre pas attention nous avons contacté
la direction elle ne nous a pas répondu
en attendant daniel pour se faire
entendre vient de déposer plainte pour
maltraitance auprès du procureur de la
république
[Musique]